in the last video we learned a little
bit about both photosynthesis it and we
know in very general terms it's the
process where we start off with photons
and water and carbon dioxide and we use
that energy and the photons to fix the
carbon and now there's this idea of
carbon fixation is essentially taking
carbon in a gaseous form in this case
carbon dioxide and fixing it into a
solid structure and that solid structure
we fix it into is a carbohydrate the
first end product of photosynthesis was
this three carbon chain this
glyceraldehyde 3-phosphate but then you
can use that to build up glucose or any
other carbohydrate so with that said
let's try to dig a little bit deeper and
understand what's actually going on in
these stages of photosynthesis remember
we said there's two stages the light
dependent reactions and then you have
the light independent reactions I don't
like using the word dark reaction
because it actually occurs while the Sun
is outside is actually occurring
simultaneously with the light reactions
it just doesn't need the photons from
the Sun but let's focus first on the
light dependent reactions the part that
actually uses photons from the Sun or
maybe I guess even photons from your
from you know the the heat lamp that you
might have in your greenhouse and uses
those photons in conjunction with water
to produce ATP and reduced reduce nad
plus nadp+ to nadph remember reduction
is gaining electrons or hydrogen atoms
and it's the same thing because when you
grain a hydrogen atom including its
electron since hydrogen is not too
electronegative you get to hog its
electron so this is both gaining a
hydrogen and gaining electron but let's
study it a little bit more so before we
dig little deep I think it's good to
know a little bit about the anatomy of a
plant so let me draw some some plant
cells so plant cells actually have cell
walls so I can draw them a little bit
rigid so let's say that these are plant
cells right here each of these squares
these quadrilaterals is a plant cell and
then in the plant cells you have these
organelles called chloroplasts remember
organelles are like organs of a cell
they're subunits membrane-bound sets
subunits of cells and of course these
cells have nucleus is in DNA and all of
the other things you normally associate
with cells but I'm not going to draw
them here I'm just going to draw the
chloroplasts and your average plant cell
and there are other and there are other
types of living organisms that perform
photosynthesis but we'll focus on plants
because that's what we tend to associate
with these plants each plant cell will
contain 10 to 50 chloroplasts
chloroplasts make them one in green on
purpose because the chloroplasts contain
chlorophyll which to our eyes appear
green but remember they're green because
they reflect green light and they absorb
red and blue and other wavelengths of
light that's why it looks green because
it's reflecting but it's absorbing all
the other wavelengths but anyway we'll
talk more about that in detail but
you'll have 10 to 50 of these
chloroplasts right here and then let's
zoom in on one chloroplast so if we zoom
in on one chloroplast let me be very
clear this thing right here is a plant
cell that is a plant cell and then each
of these green things right here is an
organelle called the chloroplasts
chloroplast and let's zoom in on the
chloroplast itself if we zoom in on one
chloroplast it has a it has a membrane
like that as a membrane that looks like
that and then the fluid inside of the
chloroplast inside of its membrane so
this fluid right here all of this fluid
that's called the stroma the stroma of
the chloroplast and then within the
chloroplast itself you have these little
stacks of these folded membranes these
little folded stacks let me see if I can
do justice here so maybe that's one two
I'm doing these stacks each of these
membrane bound you can almost view them
as pancakes
draw a couple more maybe you have some
over here just so yeah maybe you have
some over here maybe some over here so
each of these flattish looking pancakes
right here these are called thylakoids
so this right here is a thylakoid that
is a thylakoid
that's a thylakoid the thylakoid has a
membrane and this membrane is especially
important we're going to zoom in on that
in a second so it has a membrane I'll
color that in a little bit the inside of
the thylakoid so the space the fluid
inside of the thylakoid right there that
area that's light green color right
there that's called the thylakoid space
or the thylakoid lumen lumen
and just to get all of our terminology
out of the way a stack of several
thylakoids
so the stack of several thylakoids just
like that that is called a grana that's
a stack of thylakoids that is a that is
a grand and this is an organelle and you
know evolutionary biologists they
believe that organelles were once
independent organisms that then
essentially teamed up with other
organisms and started living inside of
their cells so there's actually they
have their own DNA
so mitochondria is another example of an
organelle that people believe that at
one time mitochondria or the ancestors
of mitochondria we're independent
organisms and then teamed up with other
cells and said hey if I produce your
energy maybe you'll produce give me some
food or or what not and and so they
started evolving together they turn into
one organism which makes you wonder what
you know we might evolve well anyway
that's the separate thing so there's
actually ribosomes out here so you know
that's good to think about just to
realize it at one point in the
evolutionary in evolutionary past this
organisms or this organelles ancestor
might have been an independent organism
but anyway enough about that speculation
let's zoom in again let's zoom in again
on one of on one of these thylakoid
membranes so I'm going to zoom in let me
make a box let me well I made that let
me zoom in right there so that's going
to be my zoom in
so let me make it really big just like
this so this is my zoom in box so that
little box is the same thing as this
whole box so we're zoomed in on the
thylakoid membrane so this is the
thylakoid membrane right there and it's
actually a phospholipid layer you know
it has it has your hydrophilic
hydrophobic at tails like that I mean I
could draw it like that if you like but
the important thing from photosystem
supportive view is that it's this
membrane and on the outside of the
membrane right here on the outside you
have the fluid that fills up the entire
chloroplast so here you have the stroma
and then this space right here is this
is you inside of your thigh lockwood so
this is the lumen so if I were to color
it pink right there this is your lumen
your thylakoid space and in this
membrane and this might look a little
bit familiar when you if you think about
mitochondria and the electron transport
chain what I'm going to describe in this
video actually is an electron transport
chain it might many people might not
consider it the electron transport chain
but it's the same idea same general idea
so on this membrane you have these
proteins and these complexes of proteins
and molecules that span this membrane so
let me draw a couple of them so let me
I'll call this one photosystem two and
I'm calling it that because that's what
it is
for the system - you have them maybe
another complex and these are hugely
complicated I'll do a sneak peek of
what's know photosystem two actually
looks like this is actually what
photosystem two looks like so as you can
see it truly is a complex these
cylindrical things these are proteins
these green things are chlorophyll
molecules I mean there's all sorts of
things going here and they're all
jumbled together you know I think a
complex probably is the best word it's a
bunch of proteins bunch of molecules
just jumbled together to perform a very
particular function and we're going to
describe that in a few seconds so that's
what photosystem two looks like then you
also have photosystem photosystem one
and then you have other molecules that
other complexes you have you know the
cytochrome b6f complex and I'll draw
that
this column you'll do it in a different
color right here I don't want to get too
much into the weeds because the most
important thing is just to understand so
you have other protein complexes protein
molecular complexes here that also span
the membrane but the general idea I'll
tell you the general idea then we'll go
into the specifics of what happens
during the light reaction or the light
dependent reaction dependent reaction is
you have some photons photons from the
Sun they've traveled 93 million miles so
you have some photons that go here and
they excite electrons in a chlorophyll
molecule and a chlorophyll a molecule
and actually in photosystem 2 well I
won't go into the details just yet but
they excite a chlorophyll molecule so
those electrons enter into a high energy
state I mean I shouldn't draw it like
that they enter into a high energy state
and then as they go from molecule to
molecule they keep going down in energy
state but as they go down in energy
state you have hydrogen atoms or
actually I should say hydrogen protons
without the electrons so you have all of
these hydrogen protons hydrogen protons
get pumped into the lumen they get
pumped into the lumen and so you might
remember this from the electron
transport chain the electron transport
chain has electrons went from a high
potential a high energy state to a low
energy state that energy was used to
pump hydrogen's through a membrane and
that's examined Rhea here the membrane
is the thylakoid membrane but either
case you're creating you're creating
this gradient where because of the
energy from from essentially the photons
you enter a high at the electrons enter
a high energy state to keep going into a
lower energy State and then they
actually go to photosystem one and then
they get hit by another photon or that's
a simplification that's what you can
think of it and for another high energy
state then they go to a lower lower
lower energy state but the whole time
that energy from the electrons going
from a high energy state to a low energy
state is used to pump hydrogen Pro
turns into the lumen so you have this
huge concentration of hydrogen protons
and just like just like what we saw in
in the electron transport chain that
concentration is then of hydrogen
protons is then used to drive ATP
synthase so the exact same so let me see
if I can draw that ATP synthase here so
you might remember ATP synthase looks
something like this where it literally
so here you have a huge concentration of
hydrogen protons so they'll want to go
back into the stroma from the lumen and
they do and they go through the ATP
synthase let me do it a new color so
these hydrogen protons are going to make
their way back go back down the gradient
and as they go down the gradient they
literally it's like an engine and I go
into detail on this one when I talk
about respiration and that turns
literally mechanically turns the this
top part the way I drew it of the ATP
synthase and it puts adp and phosphate
groups together it puts ADP plus
phosphate groups together to produce ATP
ATP so that's the general very high
overview and I'm going to go into more
detail in a second but this process this
process that we I just described is
called photo phosphorylation let me do
it in a nice color photo photo foss for
relation why is it called that well
because we're using photons that's the
photo part we're using light we're using
photons to excite electrons in
chlorophyll as those electrons get
passed from one molecule from one
electron acceptor to another they enter
into lower and lower energy states as
they go into lower energy states that's
used to drive literally pumps that let
allow hydrogen protons to go from the
stroma to the lumen then the hydrogen
protons want to go back they want to I
guess you could call it chemiosmosis
they want to go back into the stroma and
then that drives ATP synthase
right here this is ATP synthase ATP
synthase to essentially jam together a
DPS and phosphate groups to perform to
produce ATP now when I originally talked
about when I originally talked about the
light reactions the dark reactions I
said well the light reactions has two
byproducts it has ATP and it also has
nad actually it has three it has ATP it
and it also has NADPH NADP is reduced it
gains these electrons and these
hydrogens so where does that show up
well if we're talking about non cyclic
oxidative phosphorylation or non cyclic
light reactions the final electron
acceptor so after that electron keeps
entering lower and lower energy states
the final electron acceptor is na D P
plus so once it accepts the electrons
and a hydrogen proton with it it becomes
n a D pH now you are I also said that
part of this process water and this is
this is actually a very interesting
thing water gets oxidized to molecular
oxygen so where does that happen so when
I said appear in photosystem one that we
have a chlorophyll atom that work sorry
a chlorophyll molecule that has an
electron excited and it goes into a
higher energy state and then that
electron essentially gets passed from
one guy to the next that begs the
question what can we use to replace that
electron and it turns out that we use we
literally use the electrons in water so
over here you literally have you
literally have h2o and h2o donates the
hydrogen's and the electrons with it so
you can kind of imagine it donates two
hydrogen protons and two electrons to
replace the electron that got excited by
the photons because that electron got
passed all the way over to photosystem
one and eventually ends up in NADPH so
you're literally stripping electrons off
of water and when you strip off the
electrons and the hydrogen's you're just
left with the molecular oxygen now the
reason why I want to really
focus on this is that there's something
profound happening here at least on a
chemistry level something profound is
happening here you're oxidizing
oxidizing water and in the entire
biological Kingdom the only place where
we know something that is strong enough
of an oxidizing agent to oxidize water
to literally take away electrons from
water
which means you're really taking
electrons away from oxygen so you're
oxidizing oxygen the only place that we
know that it's an oxidation agent is
strong enough to do this is in
photosystem two so it's a very profound
idea that you know normally electrons
are very happy in water they're very
happy circulating around oxygens right
oxygen is a very electronegative atom
that's why we even call it oxidizing
because oxygen is very good at oxidizing
things but all of a sudden we found
something that can oxidize oxygen that
can strip electrons off of oxygen and
then use and then give those electrons
to the chlorophyll the electron gets
excited by photons then those photons
enter lower and lower lower energy
states get excited again in photosystem
one by another set of photons and then
enter lower and lower and lower energy
states and then finally end up at NADPH
and then the whole time it entered lower
and lower energy states that energy was
being used to pump hydrogen across this
membrane from the stroma of the lumen
and then that that gradient is used to
actually produce ATP so the next thing
I'm going to give a little bit more
context about what this means in terms
of energy states of electrons and and
what's at a higher or lower energy state
but this is essentially all that's
happening electrons get excited
electrons get excited those electrons
eventually end up at NADPH and as the
electron gets excited and goes into
lower and lower energy states it pumps
hydrogen across the gradient produce and
then that gradient is used to drive ATP
synthase to generate ATP and then that
original electron they get excited it
had to be replaced and that's act that
replaced electron is actually stripped
off of h2o so the the hydrogen protons
and the electrons of h2o is stripped
away and you're just left with molecular
our oxygen and just to get a nice
appreciation of the complexity of all of
this I showed you this earlier in the
video but this is literally a I mean
this isn't a picture of photosystem two
you actually don't have cylinders like
this but these cylinders represent
proteins these right here these green
these green kind of scaffold like
molecules
that's chlorophyll a and what literally
happens is you have photons you have
photons hitting hitting actually it
doesn't actually always have to hit
chlorophyll a can also hit what's called
antenna molecules so antenna molecules
are other types of chlorophyll and
actually other types of molecules and so
a photon or a set of photons comes here
and maybe it excites some electrons that
are in it doesn't have to be in
chlorophyll a it could be in some of
these other types of chlorophyll or in
some of these other I guess you call
them pigment molecules that will absorb
these photons and then their electrons
get excited and you can almost imagine
it as a vibration but when you're
talking about things on the quantum
level vibrations really don't make sense
but it's a good analogy they kind of
vibrate their way to chlorophyll a and
this is called this is called resonance
energy resonance
Ranas resonance energy they vibrate
their way eventually to chlorophyll a
and then in chlorophyll a you have the
electron get excited the original the
primary electron acceptor is actually
this molecule right here pheophytin some
people call it co and then from there it
gets it keeps getting passed on from one
molecule to another I'll talk a little
bit more about that in the next video
but this is fascinating I mean look how
complicated this is in order to
essentially excite electrons and then
use those electrons to well to start the
process of pumping hydrogen's across a
membrane and this is an interesting
place right here this is the water
oxidation site so I got very excited
about the idea of oxidizing water and so
this is actually where it occurs in the
photosystem ii complex that you actually
have this very complicated mechanism
because it's no joke to actually strip
away electrons and hydrogens from an
actual water molecule i'll leave you
there
in the next video I'll talk a little bit
more about these energy states and I'll
talk I'll fill in a little bit of the
gaps about what some of these other
molecules that act as as hydrogen
acceptors or you can almost sumit
electron acceptors along the process
along the way